Salut ! Comme tous les jours durant 32 jours cet été, on se fait un petit jeu, je vous donne une énigme tous les jours,
et le lendemain je vous donne la solution.
Donc aujourd'hui je commence par vous donner la solution à l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, stop !
Allez la voir tout de suite, parce que là je vais donner la réponse.
Alors je vous ai demandé en fait, pourquoi ma démonstration était fausse. A un moment donné, elle est complètement fausse.
Elle ne serait pas fausse si a ou b n'était pas égal à 1.
Mais le fait que a et b soient égaux, fait qu'il y a une erreur mathématique dans mon processus.
L'erreur est entre la sixième et la septième étape quand je simplifie une dernière fois
en enlevant le multiplicateur (a-b) de la gauche et de la droite.
Pour l'enlever, ce multiplicateur (a-b), il faudrait diviser la gauche et la droite par a-b.
Et a-b, ça fait 1-1. Et 1-1=0.
Et en mathématiques, on ne peut pas diviser par 0.
C'est impossible.
Et j'en entends déjà qui me disent: "Mais si c'est possible !"
Non ! C'est impossible !
On peut diviser par 1. Mais pas par 0.
Si je divise ce stylo en deux, je vais le casser en deux et je vais donner une moitié à chacun.
Ils auront 0,5 stylo chacun.
Si je divise ce stylo par 1 personne, je lui donne mon stylo, donc il n'a plus qu'un stylo.
Mais si je divise ce stylo par 0, il ne peut pas y avoir 0 stylo.
Il y en a forcément un au départ, donc je ne peux pas transformer ce stylo en 0, en rien du tout.
On ne peut donc pas diviser par 0.
Et c'est là où ma démonstration ne tient pas la route, et c'est pour ça que ça créé ce bug mathématique, qui fait qu'à la fin on a 2=1.
Je pense que tous ceux qui détestent les maths on kiffé cette énigme ! [rires]
Forcément !
Mais elle était assez anecdotique pour que je vous la fasse, et de toute manière, elle n'a rien à voir avec l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
Pour la neuvième énigme, on a besoin d'accessoires. Ça pourrait être des petits briquets, mais ça pourrait être aussi des piles.
Je vais le faire avec des piles.
Parce qu'on ne veut pas fumer cet été.
Cette énigme est corporelle. Vous devez mettre les piles, ou les briquets, dans chaque fourche de vos mains.
La fourche étant la jonction entre le pouce et l'index. Ici, comme ceci.
Un dans chaque main.
Et le défi, mais oui, parce qu'on est samedi et j'ai dit que le samedi des fois je ferai des petits défis.
Vous devez partir de cette position,
et finir avec cette pile
ici dans cette position là,
et cette pile ici, dans cette position là.
Mais !
Parce qu'il y a toujours un "mais" !
Vous ne devez avoir toujours qu'une seule pile par main.
Quand j'ai fait ça par exemple, c'était faux, ce n'était pas bon.
Deuxième restriction:
Les piles ne doivent jamais se toucher, s'entrechoquer ou se toucher.
Et troisième restriction et pas des moindres:
On ne peut saisir la pile qu'avec les pouces et les index.
Par exemple, vous ne pouvez pas faire quelque chose comme ça.
Vous n'avez pas le droit !
Ça c'est interdit.
Comme je suis sympa, je vous le fait quand même, en mode très très rapide.
Donc elles son bien dans la position de départ,
là, je passe ici, elles ne se sont pas touchées. Elles sont bien entre le pouce et l'index.
Et je les aient quand même séparées.
Cherchez bien, bon courage ! Si vous avez la solution, vous ne le dites pas dans les commentaires. Vous pouvez en parler mais laissez les autres chercher.
Si vous trouvez, vous mettez un pouce en l'air !
Et ça nous servira de compteur pour savoir quel est le nombre de personnes qui a réussi à résoudre cette énigme.
Cette énigme là, qui est d'ailleurs plus un défi qu'une énigme.
Passez un bon samedi soir, faites bien la fête si vous faites la fête, profitez du soleil si il y en a là où vous êtes.
Passez plutôt un bel été ! N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine, car le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11H.
Ciao !